Хоча квантові комп'ютери не підходять для розв'язання
всіх задач, існує кілька класів проблем
і потенційних сфер застосування, де ми очікуємо,
що квантові обчислення матимуть вплив.
Серед них — моделювання,
наприклад опис процесів і систем, що існують
у природі; пошук і оптимізація —
тобто пошук найкращого або
оптимального рішення в ситуації з
безліччю можливих відповідей; а також математика
та обробка даних зі складною структурою,
включно із застосуваннями для машинного навчання.
Квантові алгоритми пропонують новий підхід до
таких задач, використовуючи
унікальні властивості квантової фізики, як-от
суперпозиція, інтерференція та заплутаність.
Звичайні комп'ютери застрягають,
досліджуючи певні ділянки обчислювального простору,
і тому не можуть знайти ці закономірності.
Квантові комп'ютери наділені
додатковими можливостями або підвищеною продуктивністю
для деяких задач завдяки своїй квантовій природі.
Щоб повністю зрозуміти потенціал квантових комп'ютерів,
потрібно глибоко зануритися в теорію обчислювальної складності —
галузь інформатики, яка зосереджена на
вимірюванні та порівнянні обчислювальних зусиль,
необхідних для розв'язання задач різних видів.
Це дає корисну основу
для опису різних прискорень
і класів задач, з якими стикаються в
обчисленнях.